اكثر من 26 الرياضيا وفنانا وطبيبا
يواجهون خطرا لاعدام في ايران بعضهم قضى
محاكمات سوريه دون اتاحت اي تمثيل قانوني
من بين هؤلاء لاعب كره القدم السابق امير
نصر ازاداني والذي اعتقل في اصفهان في
الثامنه عشر من نوفمبر الماضي حكم عليه
بالاعدام بتهمه الخيانه والتمرد المسلح
على الدوله رياضيون اخرون مصيرهم مشابه
ينتظرون حكما بالاعدام او انه صدر بالفعل
ولم يخرج للعلم الرياضي محمد مهدي كرامه
حكم عليه بالاعدام بعد اذنته بالفساد في
الارض والاعتداء على احد عناصر المسيج
خلال الاحتجاجات في كراج المصارع سهيل
جيهان جيري اعتقل في السادسه عشر من
نوفمبر شهر نوفمبر شهد ايضا اعتقال صالح
ميرشمي وهو مدرب بطل منتخب الكاراتيه ولا
يزال قيد الاستجواب القوات الامنيه
الايرانيه اعتقلت ايضا نسيانك سيمكان وهو
متسلق صخور في شيراز نوبي البلاد وقبل ذلك
اعدمت المصارع مجيد رضا
رهنرد بعد 23 يوما على اعتقاله
[موسيقى]